half of Americans don't want a theist
in-laws and atheists in their family
this is really nuts I have a feeling
Jacqueline's gonna have a little
something to say about this a Pew
Research Center poll s Americans whether
they would be disappointed if a close
family member married someone of a
different race different country
different political party or someone who
doesn't believe in God the scariest of
all things let's look at the study's
findings 49% of Americans said they
would be disappointed if their family
member
married an atheist people I cannot
believe that 73 percent of conservatives
said they would be less than thrilled if
a family member married an atheist and
nearly a quarter of Americans who call
themselves consistently liberal and 41
percent of mostly liberal respondents so
they wouldn't want an atheist to marry
into their family so that's the one I
want to start with a quarter of liberals
I mean we're supposed to be the ones
that are forward-thinking and open to
other ideas and one out of four liberals
does not want you in their family Jaclyn
Glenn go I think it just goes along with
a misconception that atheists have no
morals that were not good people I mean
none of those numbers surprised me
because I've been around this for a long
time I know how distrusted we're like
the most distrusted group of people yeah
in this country there's many studies
that say that I mean there there was a
study one time where they asked people
if there was an abandoned car and it was
you know if somebody went through and
stole everything out of it would you
expect that this person was you know a B
C and one of the options was like you
know rapist-murderer
atheist and it's like oh definitely the
atheist that was the highest chosen
answer and it's like really I mean
whenever it all these different studies
are lined up we are on par with rapists
and murderers yes as far as you know the
lack of trust goes and that's it's
fascinating and I think most of that
just because there's such a stigma
behind it because people think that you
have to have religion to have morality
or some sort of spirituality and to say
that you know you're on your own without
that is very scary to a lot of people
yeah so quick before I let you jump in
Hank so how does an atheist get morals
if not being and
down to them by the Lord everyone has
morals and if you follow the morals
handed down to you by the Lord you'd end
up in jail a lot I mean yeah you know
killing your kids and stuff and there's
actually that's happening now a lot of
people with the faith healing and stuff
they're not getting their kids the
medical term that they need and you know
whenever they're obviously you know
repeat offenders cuz they let one kid
die and then another kid dies then they
go to jail you know the first ones okay
yeah but I mean it's it's happening now
people are following you know the word
of the Bible and that's happening yeah
so so what do you make of the of the
quarter of the Liberals because that's
the number here that you know the
conservative thing all right I get it
like if you're more conservative and
you're more religious then I can
understand this I don't agree with it
but I can understand it a quarter of
liberals that's a lot I'd like to see
how they broke down the word liberal
because the rule doesn't necessarily
mean not religious yeah you know so a
lot of liberals actually are do still
identify with some kind of faith and I
think people in general it's human that
you want to see yourself reflected in in
others and those are the ones you
gravitate more towards anyways because
America is such a I would say a spirit
has such a strong spiritual foundation
that it just seeps into everyone's way
of life and so when they run into
someone who completely rejects all of
that and we're and we're talking not
just Christianity which i think is
probably the most prevalent of religions
here but when they're like we mean you
don't even believe in Oprah and energies
that the universe ends like yeah and all
they like that's we like why who did
this to you in your life to make you
turn out so horribly yeah I mean I think
another thing about this is like
whenever you think about the word
liberal a lot of times whenever you
identify something you expect that
everyone in that you know category is
like this awesome you know open-minded
free thinking person and I've learned
the hard way that even within the
Atheist community you can't expect all
of them to be open-minded and free
thinking interesting so there is
discrimination even within the Atheist
community because you're human beings
you know just because you're a liberal
or a conservative or an atheist or a
Christian or whatever I mean there's
still those human tendencies that make
certain people horrible I mean you can
be a bad person and an atheist or a
Christian or whatever
you know there's there's bad people
everywhere how much of this do you guys
think has to do with tradition more than
religion per se because I could see well
I'm not religious per se but I do like
some of the traditions like during
Passover I will have a seder I like the
tradition of it it doesn't have a
religious connotation to me really so I
could see why someone would say oh I
don't want someone coming into my family
who's not gonna care about the the
traditions more than the religion itself
I can see that yeah I can see that being
a thing but I think most of it is just
people are scared of atheists yeah I
mean even if you sat there and said I'm
not religious that would go over
completely differently than atheist you
know like I've heard stories people you
know saying that they're not religious
or they're not atheist and and the
response is well I can understand you're
not believing in God but it's like like
nihilists or something like they have no
belief system whatsoever is that well I
mean maybe but that's just a
misconception and what is your personal
definition how why do you label yourself
an atheist I don't believe in God okay
that's it that's all do you think we
need more atheists to come out of the
closet I've talked about this a couple
of times when we've done this before
that you know even somebody like Barney
Frank who was once open well so he was
really gay in the 80s in Congress I
think he came out like 1982 or 1983 had
an incredibly proficient career and then
he didn't come out as an atheist until
about a month after he resigned last
year so atheists are actually behind gay
people in the in their exposure to pot
so you're what you're trying to say Dave
is that atheist rights are the new trans
rights this is what you're trying to say
trans people are just getting their
rights but there's not even time for
that I'm sorry we're really push I know
we could just deal with one thing at a
time exactly I danced your question yes
I think it's very important because I do
believe that atheists are misrepresented
and
stood in this country yeah I assume that
you think more atheists need to come as
someone that publicly is doing this all
the time yeah I mean there's such a
stigma and I feel like the only way to
get rid of that is to you know say hey
I'm a normal happy nice person and I'm
an atheist you know
[Music]